I'm Nancy kanwisher and I'm an
investigator at the McGovern Institute
for brain research until recently it's
been very difficult to study the neural
basis of cognition because this was sort
of thought to happen all over the brain
and a kind of disorganized wait it was
very controversial whether high-level
aspects of cognition thinking are
organized into compartmentalize separate
fits years ago I had a really brilliant
graduate student in Rebecca Saxe who
said that she wanted to look for brain
regions that are involved in how we
think about what another person is
thinking and I thought that was a pretty
cool question but I just didn't believe
for a moment that the brain had
specialized regions for things that are
that abstract and boy was I wrong the
region of the brain that's selectively
involved in thinking about what another
person is thinking is a prime candidate
for a region that will be affected in
autism I all as best as anybody can tell
the core deficit in autism is one of
being able to understand other people's
thoughts Nancy is the perfect example of
someone who spent her whole life
understanding human cognition and in
recent years applying brain imaging
technology to understanding you in
cognition ready and now she's going to
take a battery of these tasks to get
that very basic understanding of what is
it that's going wrong in the brains of
these kids suffering from autism
hi I think when Jackson was about to
when most parents are expecting their
children to start making sounds and say
words he said a couple things he said
Kitty and he said daddy he never
actually lost any language but he just
didn't gain any more words than that I
think those signs were enough as an
educator for me to know that there was
something up you hear things about you
know children who are on the autism
spectrum who just love street signs or
just love music he loves everything I
love books they are really fun to read I
recently read diary of a wimpy kid book
free when we walked in to the McGovern
Institute he was just flabbergasted I
think he wanted to go out and come back
in again because he just didn't know
what to think about it and then he just
got comfortable there very quickly what
was nice about the passport for Jackson
was he he could have something tangible
this is when i got my brain scan and
there's a pager something to carry
around with them all day
it's an x-ray view and it's I like an
x-ray of you enjoy body when I hold it
up like this scanning any kids is tricky
right at the edge of what you can do in
neuroscience research they're looking
for the things of they're looking for
kiki is of autism inside my brain it's
pretty freaky I tell everybody that we
are at MIT doing this because the finger
is on the pulse there the fact that we
could go in and get a picture of his
brain I mean where else can you do that
do you think what you're doing is gonna
help some other kids yeah I know I know
it will help we're hoping that we'll
discover not just a characterization of
this disorder and what it looks like but
that will also discover distinct
subtypes of autism and if we can
discover that there are three or even
ten different kinds of autism that will
be major progress autism is an
incredibly complex disorder that just
isn't understood at all so this is a
much harder problem than anything I've
tried to do before on the other hand the
stakes are higher it really matters
you